this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice number one best-selling author
ken coleman is my co-host today ramsey
personality sitting along my side here
he is host of the ken coleman show where
they talk about careers and purpose and
jobs and getting one a purpose and a job
and how about mixing them together
that'd be a good idea well he can help
you with all of that so you got
questions about jobs and careers in this
crazy world we live in right now
uh well we're here to help you got
questions about life and money we're
here to help the phone number is triple
eight eight two five
five
two two five
you know ken our ratings uh on the show
have gone up substantially during these
wacky times because the um
and i have a i have a theory
on this
have you noticed that the world has gone
nuts
yes
yes lost their minds out there
what is wrong with you people
yeah
so i mean yeah it's just uh uh it's a
thing and so
and and like we're still sane and stuff
oh yeah like you know like we believe in
like the truth and the law of gravity
still will cause you to hit the sidewalk
when you jump off a building and stuff
like that there are some things you can
believe in that are true and safe and
calm and kindness does matter
not just anger
and our pulse rate hasn't changed so
people are like why how how come they're
not scared over there at ramsey
solutions how come how come they're not
lost their minds
um because we actually believe in solid
things and teach solid things and so
the great news about the stuff we teach
here whether it's in the career area the
mental health area the marriage area the
money area certainly is
it works in crazy times and it works in
regular times
and so i guess everybody went you know i
need some calmness in my life i need
some stability in my life i need an
anchor
that is based on actual facts not
people just making up crap which seems
to be a thing
like you know the old joke was 88
percent of the statistics are made up on
the spot right and so i think it's 98
but it's like right now yeah then 88 of
science is made up on the spot so um oh
geez there he went and did it i did it i
did it i went there he just did it i did
it so but i mean it's just and people
are lost their dad got up number 11 yeah
and you know we could have said this
exact same little rant right here about
18 months ago and we've still been
accurate but yeah right now it's just
we're we have the second wave of crazy
coming through we went through the
pandemic
and now we're going through the economic
tsunami that is the the delayed you know
when where does a tsunami come from an
earthquake way out in the ocean
so the pandemic was the earthquake way
out in the ocean now we've got supply
chain labor shortages
product shortages hyperinflation
you know stinking if you notice the
price of your gasoline going into your
car five dollars a gallon today in new
york
five dollars a gallon and i saw another
headline that and they don't even drive
there no they don't they don't uh you
know it's interesting what we talk about
here ramsey solutions whatever category
that you just listed out the reality is
is that when you've got discipline when
you've got a plan when the crazy times
hit and they will
you don't have to go crazy but everybody
else is going crazy because they weren't
ready for it they don't know what to do
they don't know how to get out of it and
you're right it is a very interesting
time right now where there are some
people dave that are trying to elongate
the panic i got my existential crisis
out of the way about 30 years ago so i'm
kind of i kind of got that one in my
rearview mirror i went ahead and had my
mid-life crisis early yeah and so um i
was always an overachiever so raised the
bar so high it's just like i was 27
years old so i mean i went broke lost
everything the kids you know i couldn't
feed the kids and i lost my mind and i
didn't know what i was going to do and
so that's all kind of back there ways
and so i'm kind of like some of this
other stuff hits i just yawn now i'm
like oh is that all it is here's
something i've i've never asked you on
the show and i want to ask you because
it's really relevant
do you notice a difference between the
headlines and what you see every day we
travel the country uh still
we live here in tennessee
i just see a huge disparity between what
we're being told is going on versus what
i see every day do you sense that
well i've been in five states in 15 days
just recently i mean in the last 15 days
i've been traveling we were doing stuff
with radio i was doing stuff with
uh when i spoke at liberty university
and so
um
yeah i i and i'm i'm sad to say
that both sides of the media because
there's not like a media anymore there's
the right media left media
and uh they both lie
all the time
uh if it bleeds it leads you know and so
i you know the right-hand media is
telling you that you know that you if
you go to california it's all shut down
and the governor is a you know whatever
and the whole the whole thing i went out
to orange county and i was like nothing
going on that's what i'm talking walking
around normal and yeah i went to
restaurants and a couple of the servers
had masks on but i mean it was about
like it is here in nashville and uh you
know
fewer rednecks but i mean it's just but
it was um
but it was just i mean it was like i
expected based on the news media to
think i was going to russia right you
know the right-hand news media and of
course the left-hand news media would
have you believe that we're all going to
die tomorrow and so you might as well
get you know whatever living you have
left out of the way because friday's
coming and so um but i mean and you know
and i don't see that out there either
that's my point
i i just
i quit watching them i i some a lot of
them are friends of mine that's good and
i i just had to turn them off because as
my old friend zig ziglar used to say he
said i get up every morning and i read
the bible read the newspaper so i can
tell what both sides are doing
and so so good classic zig classic
ziggler but he's right you know it's
like if you took
inputs will screw up your mind
yeah and uh and you join the crazy you
join the fray right i got a friend of
mine watching cnn and fox all right
we're gonna have to put the boy in a
rubber room he's gonna lose it he's
gonna he's it's just gonna well his
brain is draining out of his ears so
what you watch what you listen to
who you listen to who you hang out with
dramatically affect our decisions so
some of this crazy is a result of we're
paying attention to the wrong things
yeah it's like step off the
crazy people are in charge that's the
problem who knew
let's see that's that's the myth too
they're not in charge
i mean there's all kinds of nonsense
going on in dc right now every day well
that's asking yourself how does that
affect your day-to-day life
get off of the crazy merry-go-round and
realize you have a lot to do with you
yeah a lot more than you realize it it
affected me when i went to the gas pump
sure of course it affected me a few
other times but overall
other than that it didn't really affect
me except to the extent i chose to
cram this trashy input into my brain
every day
and then try to exist in a normal world
the only time i got nervous dave
was when the toilet paper got got dicey
that was that was a little scary got up
to the old neighborhood grocery store
couldn't find any toilet paper i just
officially got nervous that was the only
time shook me for about 10 minutes and
then i realized
we'll adjust and then i got over it
aren't you glad i shared that with you
yeah and you have to know that if the
biggest crisis that you've had in your
life
was tp you're blessed you're in pretty
good shape buddy
you're just pretty good shape i'm just
saying that that's everything daniel
boone didn't have tps and he made it
which is why i adjusted it after 10
minutes davey crockett they figured it
out no tp but he figured out a way
didn't have american express he left
home without it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle
and author of the new book from paycheck
to purpose it is in pre-sale right now
comes out in a couple of weeks in
november the clear path to doing work
you love from paycheck to purpose if you
buy it now at ramsey solutions while
it's in pre-sale you get the e-book the
audiobook and about a hundred dollars
worth of odds and ends goodies that we
throw in with the book to get you to buy
it pre-sale we bribe you
so come and get you one right now from
paycheck to purpose the clear path to
work you love it'll be ken coleman's
second number one i'm praying and hoping
and wishing and maybe what do you think
i you know i think it's going to do well
we didn't know when we wrote it a year
and a half ago that we were going to
come into this type of an environment
and so we think it's going to help a lot
of people um and and that's what we're
praying for is that it just really
strikes a chord and helps people realize
there is a clear path
55 percent of american workers struggle
with burnout it's real right now if you
want to change jobs this year more than
half of america's workforce are
looking to leave their cruddy jobs so
they can find something better it's
called the great resignation
uh but before you do that uh you need to
ask yourself what do i like about my
current job what do i not like about my
current job what does my dream job look
like what do i need to do if i want to
have my dream job don't just leave for
more money that's what paycheck's
purpose is all about it's exactly right
you know at the end of the day
you want to do work that makes great
income but also tremendous impact to you
that's when you start throwing around
phrases like dream job
well and here's the thing
what you think
is going to make you happy might fool
you
absolutely right um
my contention is that a bazillion of
these people that are working from home
are going to find really quickly that
they're lonely
as a matter of fact we're having people
from the technology field
the developers and and the
creatives and the digital world the data
scientists that's the type of thing you
can do remote pretty easy
as far as the technical job goes but
there's zero community in that and
there's zero human touch and the
productivity goes down
uh but it sounds it sounds kind of cool
i'm at home with my kids i get to see my
kids more i'm at home more and and the
truth is the mit studies and the other
studies are coming out already it didn't
take long for this idea of work from
home to meltdown uh remote work to
meltdown and uh we're gonna see a return
to of those people that made a mistake
they thought they were gonna find
happiness there and they didn't so what
the problem is is not the uh not the
work from home is a flawed system the
the flaw the problem is is that you
you thought that that was going to make
you happy because you didn't like the
people you worked with now right well
you fell in love with seeing the kids
run around you think environments going
to make you happy you know you just
mentioned developers we get some
world-class developers here and they
came from big big companies very
impressive resumes but they come join us
because of the contribution that they're
making they see a missional result to
their work so it's not just the paycheck
it's not just the love of the work it's
the results of the work as well and
you've got to be able to see that
because everything wears off everything
shiny wears off so don't take you got
listen you got if you're right now
you're looking for a job
you got your choice you really do you
can just pick
okay there's there's you know there's
more people looking for jobs than jobs
and so you can
you can i mean there's more jobs than
people looking for jobs i'm sorry so you
it's a buyer's market you can you can
just choose so here's the thing
don't choose based only on money that's
right that's not gonna make you happy
don't choose based only on environment
like i get to work at home that that
you got to make a choice that's deeper
than just those surface things and get
down into the purpose of what you're
doing and plug into that and if you
don't do that the environment changing
the money change is not going to fix
your life no it will and here it is the
very simple depth that dave talking
about is this talent what you do best
passion work you love
mission results that matter to you when
all three come into alignment you're
gonna love showing up
that's how it works
huh william is with us in greenville
south carolina hi william how are you
i'm doing great dave and ken it's an
honor to speak to you congratulations on
what you are doing for america well
thank you sir how can we help today yes
well i first heard you
long long time ago when i lived in
nashville working at applebee's and
anyway i've realized that i didn't have
the right size shovel and so i've worked
my whole life until i have the right
size shovel i believe
but um in my wife and i've been
debt-free but i've but i'm
kind of in steps four five and six i've
already well i've paid for my children's
college
but i've arrived at the age of 53
without
saving 15 and without paying off my
house
and i'm just wondering
you know to work from 53 to 63. i don't
think 50 15 percent will get me there
should i should i break the money that
i'm able to save now 50 50 and do that
or should i focus more on
um
i've just never trusted the stock market
but you know you preach it every day and
i'm just wondering
at 53 what would you do
well we don't have to do anything in
baby step five four is fifteen percent
of your income going into retirement and
everything else going towards the house
how much do you owe on your home
about 500 000 okay and what's your
household income
about this between fluctuates because i
owned i had i actually had to start the
company to get my shovel right but it's
it's between 800 and
850 900 depending on just depends on the
year
but it hasn't always been that way
i got to catch my breath here a little
second did you just say 800 000 a year
yes sir okay and you don't think 15 is
going to get you there
no okay well i mean well let's do it
let's do it let's do a little math okay
uh
year one
you live on three hundred thousand
dollars and you pay off your home
well wait a minute
let's pay taxes on that eight to nine so
let's call it five
is that fair okay it takes two years
and you live on 250.
why
okay i'm not i'm not i know i'm just
giving you a hard time 55 years old your
house is paid for and you make 8.50 and
you own the company
so what is the destiny of this company
upon retirement
um
it will be sold
it's a garbage company and what we do
is um
it's really worth asset value at the end
it's there's really not a big pot of
gold the gold comes as you work it
you can't sell it while it's being
worked for this tremendous cash flow
um
no it's it's it's not it's not that type
of company i mean i know what you're
talking about you hear these
big big companies come in and swoop in
and pay you know because most companies
that you make 800 000 of your profit on
you could sell the company
well
i just i've just i just know that people
that do what i do they sell i mean i
read the trade rags they sell their
companies for asset value at the end
so your truck so i'm really not looking
not looking for a big lick yeah trucks
and dumpsters and stuff yes yeah all
right well done
very well done well thank you love it
proud of you
um in the old book the millionaire next
door
and uh there's a few other pieces of
literature out in the millionaire stuff
that uh one of the um
most likely to become very wealthy by
the way is your trade
it's a it's a dirty little secret no pun
intended so um
but uh
but so okay here we do so you're 55
years old you make 800 000 a year you
don't have a payment in the world and so
how much are we going to bank a year
after of your 500 after taxes how much
you're going to put in mutual funds
um
from that point from that point forward
because you're at baby step seven two
years from now
right
so so you're saying
pay your house off and then
save three or four hundred thousand
dollars a year mutual fund so two or
three yeah yeah i'm saying it doesn't
matter
if you flip it and do it the other way
you're still gonna get there
because you're right you you don't have
a shovel you have a truck in fact you
have a whole fleet of trucks yeah you're
just counting that's amazing so your
income is your answer um yeah just get
but just lay out a very intentional plan
to say i'm going to invest this much
i'll pay this house off pull home just
like that
wow yeah unbelievable not to mention
what he could save from his company buy
some other assets that make money
unbelievable
man
[Music]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1000 to twenty five hundred
dollars off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five jesus and susan
are with us in san antonio says on my
screen you guys are debt free
congratulations
thank you yes we are
awesomeness how much did you pay off
we paid off 46 027
months good for you and your range of
income during that time
uh roughly around 60 000. okay cool what
kind of debt was the 46 000
oh everything credit cards student loans
cars personal loans couches family loan
you know mostly irresponsible day
and jesus kind of wraps it all up
i love it well done so you guys were
like normal
very yeah how old are you guys 32
um i'm 30 how old am i 36. i'm 34. yeah
i hit it pretty close almost like i've
done this before
okay so uh and 46 almost 48 almost four
years ago
something changed
and you start on this ramsey journey
what happened
it did well we were living
i wouldn't even say it barely paycheck
to paycheck you know i joke that scotch
tape barely held
together the the ends
it was a lot of credit cards and a lot
of praying until we got to the next
month
um
and i had heard of you before you know
growing up a good southern baptist girl
we'd heard of i'd heard of you before
but and i knew like the whole envelope
thing which we tried but a friend of
mine was reading the book and so finally
i read the book and went oh
that's what you do
and just
sick and tired of being sick and tired
so we buckled down and we did it
we did
so jesus she comes in she read this book
and she said uh we're about to change
everything what'd you say
i didn't like it at all whatsoever i am
not the kind of likes to wait but um
mostly like anything i if i mean
somebody asked me i'm gonna say i don't
like it but i respect it because it
works and i'm gonna continue to use it
ah that's powerful
he was so mad his doctor he had went to
a doctor's appointment and he was
brooding about it the doctor was ready
to put him on like antidepressants and
he's he was like no no it's just the
budget i don't like it man i'm gonna go
ahead and grow up and get over it
wow
i don't need drugs i just gotta grow up
i like you man this is fun you guys are
great
all right this is a long track 46 000 oh
i said 48 months there's 46 thousand
dollars over 27 months i did it wrong
yeah you didn't even correct me you let
me do that and so you did it in two
little over two years ago you started
the process and
and so what is the uh the secret to
getting out of debt your ex your pros
you did it
the budget yes
budget and and like rachel says it gives
you permission to spend so it takes away
that guilt
like you know you have a clothing budget
you can actually go spend that but then
tightening the budget you know quit
paying attention to where your money's
going is a huge thing because we just
ate out or we bought this or both that
and it was just whatever credit cards
yay
when you pay attention it really makes a
difference
and once you learn to wait that's when
things really start coming together for
me it did anyway
you know that whole adults devise a plan
and follow what children
do what feels good thing hey sis you
mentioned uh that obviously you didn't
like to wait and then susan brings this
home tells you about it to the point
that your doctor almost misdiagnoses you
how long did it take for you to go okay
i i'm gonna start
waiting and be disciplined how long did
it take effect we saw one of uh dave
ramsey we saw him live at a church in
round rock
and uh just hearing more of his stories
and more of uh the realities of uh you
know how king hawk can suck sometimes it
was kind of a turning point for me and
just i just had to buckle down and that
was like four or five months after i had
brought the book home because i was like
he's nearby let's go it's free it's
church service let's go
[Laughter]
church is free yeah you always tweet
that right before you you preach at a
church i love that oh
well because i get accused of everything
else so why not
but um
yeah way to go guys i'm so proud of
y'all
who were outside the two of you who was
cheering you on
i it was mostly each other to be honest
yes
and i became obsessive with the podcast
so i listened to it quite a bit and it
kept me motivated which then i would
bring home
and it's funny how it works we both had
little moments of weakness and when i
would get a little weak she she cheered
me on and when she would get a little
weak i would cheer her on it's just
the way it works in a marriage yeah it's
it when it's working that's how it works
you're right that's exactly the way it's
supposed to be we have a shared goal
and we're gonna we're gonna encourage
and hold accountable and we're gonna
lock arms and we're gonna get there
together it's a shared goal
and that's what makes all the difference
in the world we find very few couples
where one of them fights against it that
actually make it
uh they know that we do
they're very seldom become wealthy if
they're fighting against us so working
together is everything yeah jesus
changed our marriage before i was very
resentful of him and his
like like to spend money and dream of of
money and what we can do with it and i'm
like we can't pay the bills right now
stop dreaming
but it changed everything you did
your program really helped us really
help our marriage a lot hey i want to
ask you a follow-up on what you said
jesus i thought this was really great
coming off of what dave said as well
that both of you had areas of weakness
but you were strong for each other
that's really important to be able to
own that that this isn't a perfect
process
do you mind sharing each of you really
quickly for other couples where were you
weak and then how did you come along and
actually encourage each other
you guys there
i think we lost them yeah see what
happens when ken coleman answered
at first i thought oh i stumped him
there was that time oh wait a minute
they're done are you guys with us
no no technical difficulties yeah
i don't know maybe uh
maybe kelly maybe kelly messed it up you
think kelly messed it up i'm not going
to say that because i'm scared i still
see him on the screen and i can't talk
to him and it's got to be kelly's fault
it did well i'm going to go with that
i'm going with it it's kelly's fault oh
i'm getting the death stare
in the darth vader death stare that's
pretty good hey i'll ask that question
of you i mean when you and sharon
started it
i mean the very first time that a couple
went through this
uh
were you weak in an area and and because
i know you like to spin you tell people
that and sharon came in and vice versa
what was that like for you all
um
you know our weakness might have been
that we were so beat up and beat down
that we were just afraid yeah
um that might have been our weakness
and so it was like lost confidence and
that kind of a thing
and so she would say yes we can still do
it because i was always the one yeah you
can do the show you can do this and then
when i got you know i just one of the
things i lost was my confidence my
self-esteem was yeah because i lost a
company we lost our income we got a
brand new baby i can't feed my family
i'm 28 years old i was crushed
and so uh one thing she did was just
lift me back up in that regard okay
kelly did her magic because she's magic
um and got jesus and susan back on the
line maybe hey guys are you there
hey okay good sorry about that i have no
idea what kelly did to hang up on you
but um
we're sticking with it so uh hey susan
susan i i don't know if you heard the
question but it doesn't matter now
because we're out of time i want to get
you to be able to do your your debt free
scream i'm so proud of you we got a copy
of the legacy journey for you that's the
next chapter in your story to be
everyday millionaires you're on your way
congratulations a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away for
someone to start their journey way to go
you guys all right jesus and susan san
antonio texas 46 000
paid off in 27 months making 66 000 a
year count it down let's hear a debt
free scream
three two one where's that free
[Music]
[Applause]
that's a deal right there man
well done well done well done well done
man
and we actually
technically pulled that off all in one
segment got them back on that was yeah
that was flawless phone screening for
somebody that messed it up
if dave doesn't make it back folks to
the next break i'll be here for the
break we'll still take your calls if my
body is found in a field
south of nashville oh dear people know
what happened
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
ken coleman ramsey personality number
one best-selling author and author of
the brand new book from paycheck to
purpose the clear path to getting the
career you love hey it's on sale now at
ramsey solutions be sure you jump in and
get you one while you can brian is with
us in indianapolis hi brian how are you
well maybe he's not i think we're having
a little issue here all right let's try
ellen in san antonio hi ellen how are
you
hi dave i'm doing great how about you
better than i deserve what's up
um all right so my situation is i took a
job back in july
and
this was after completing an internship
there through my uh
my graduate degree um the woman that was
supervising my internship put in a good
word for me the job that i took was not
um
it wasn't directly related to social
work as far as like advancing my career
but it was similar to what i was doing
so i decided to make the jump however
i realized since taking that job that
it's not really hitting the areas that
that light me up and
help me
do or make the impact that i'm
i'm able to make and so i started
looking for a new job
however
now that i've had three
two or three successful interviews and
the potential to take a new job
this place had a position open up and my
supervisor came to me and basically said
that they are looking to to really lean
on me and my
my uh
my social work abilities in order to uh
to fill that position and
and provide like medicaid services and
connecting our youth with that
so where i'm at right now is i'm trying
to figure out if i need to stay
because
the person that i have a personal
connection with who got me in that
position
is telling me they
they're going to need me or if
i should
continue looking or potentially take one
of the jobs that i'm going to have on
the table
and and start doing things that are more
like case management and will
directly teach me more about the field
and advance my career in the long term
sure
well the answer is you need to make the
decision that puts you on the right
ladder or moves you up the right ladder
okay and so
this this supervisor has come to you how
specific are we talking about are they
saying hey hang in there for six more
months or it's going to be available in
30 days how specific is this opportunity
or has it been discussed in specific
terms
they came to me yesterday and they told
me by the end of the week they wanted to
start training me on it and the position
would be posted within the next week or
so
well i certainly would walk this out
because you know it's it's unlikely
you're going to have an interview or two
ready to go or even if you do by the end
of this week you've already been
interviewing right
yes i've already been interviewing and i
have two very likely job offers based on
how
how those interviews work and all three
of these jobs are what you want to do
yes so the one that would require me to
stay at my current place i'm employed
it's probably the least
new like it's it has no more advancement
opportunities in that direct position
but i would still be working with my
internship supervisor and and learning
some important things about
service provision and resource
coordination the other two are case
management positions
and i would be learning a lot more about
um that's the answer that's the answer
the other two give you much more
advancement opportunities and they're
what you want to do the only reason
you're hanging on is this a relationship
with a supervisor yeah and the problems
are just too nice yeah
yeah you don't need to feel guilt by the
way i get this call a lot uh that well
they hired me right out of school yeah
it's great uh but but leave the right
way and i think you're more worried
people are more worried about what
they're going to say about us when we
leave and the reality is you've got to
do what's right for you 25 years from
now nobody's going to remember the
supervisor including you yeah
yeah that's a that's a good point and so
you know what is it it's not being
selfish or greedy or ungrateful or any
of those things it's you're not any of
those you don't even have that bone in
your body you're just a sweet person
and that's what that's what's troubling
you is just a commatter of conscience
and so if the supervisor and the
relationship there and the the sense of
loyalty to them was not in the picture
you take one of the other two jobs in
about 30 seconds right
yeah absolutely that's what you need to
do
the act of moving forward ellen and for
everybody listening today the act of
moving forward means we will leave
people behind and we got to get over it
leave them well be classy treat them the
way that you would want to be treated be
grateful but do what's right for you so
how old are you
24 okay
uh you got any really great friends from
high school that
uh
went down the rabbit hole and you didn't
uh yes i do yeah you left them behind
didn't you
i did that's that's what ken's talking
about
uh every one of us have that from high
school by the way we've all got someone
someone that we stay in contact with
that we love and someone that we really
thought we were gonna be friends for
life and uh we just went down extremely
different paths and they either left us
behind or we left them behind or
something right and that's true when you
leave leave
any kind of a thing like that including
a a former position you're you're
they're leaving you behind you're
leaving them behind whatever it is i i
think you just go in and you do you quit
with a lot of gratitude it's been my
honor to work here what you've done for
me has meant the world for me your
appreciation of me
has made this a hard decision
and you take the other job
all right i really appreciate it and
congratulations ellen you've earned this
the best is yet to come go
are you going to are you going to do it
are you gonna do it
i really i really think i am it's
it's a hard thing just because she's
she's a mentor to me and so and you know
what you know what if she is she will
continue to be
and she'll be happy for you
sad issues
if she really if she really is
because i've got i've got friends that
have worked here for 10 years and then
they left and went did something else
and i'm sad when they leave but i also
celebrate their successes out there
um
and there's a whole bunch of them that
used to work here that are successful
somewhere else now and on their own
started their own businesses and i'm
really sad that they're not here for
multiple reasons but relationally as
well and uh but i'm a real mentor and so
i really still love them and i'm really
still cheering for them um
and uh
with absolutely no economic ties
whatsoever so uh that's
that's the thing it is hard though it is
isn't it great though that she's got
that kind of character because a lot of
people don't they just go see ya i
didn't even know this term it's like
ghosting until about a year or two like
unfriending someone on facebook you know
it's like about that cold yeah like as
if they were really a friend in the
first place no one has eight thousand
friends come on right
i got four and a half million apparently
but i'm really not really that friendly
with any of them i i like all of you i'm
sure or most of you but um
but you know i i don't you know it's not
your real friend
you know you know what's going on here
and i hear this on a regular basis is
what we fail to realize is the
psychology of what she's talking about
and the psychology of this at a base
level is that it's confrontation even
though you're not going in and griping
you're not going in with an axe to grind
but the very nature of sitting across
from somebody and you got to go i'm
breaking up with you but it's not you
it's me
i think it is it's and so it's yucky
nobody well
i couldn't say nobody i think you and i
enjoy a good confrontation when it's
good yeah but these people but even but
even but a breakup i i you know that's
what
because there's always a tearing
there's always a tearing and so i'm not
trying you know i mean unless it's a
unless it's a violent breakup and it
needs to be violent right um but i mean
most of the time it's it's just you know
it's i
it's just this thing is a necessary
ending that's what it is as henry cloud
says yeah yeah and so
yeah it's uh but that's powerful that
that young lady at 24 years old has that
deep sense of loyalty and honor
that's powerful and uh by the way that
is a character trait that is rare enough
that it gives you a superpower it
certainly does when you have it and
here's the thing on this
you you know we talk about all the time
at ramsey solutions control the
controllables in a situation like this
where you're leaving somebody and a
company you can only control how you act
so don't fret i know it's hard but don't
fret over how they act you can only act
classy yeah and grateful and then move
on yeah you can't you can't decide how
they're gonna be
that's exactly right
wow
ken coleman good
hour that's just this hour of the ramsay
show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host king
coleman ramsey personality is my co-host
today you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five claudio is in west palm beach
florida hi claudio how are you
i'm well dave thank you so much for
taking my call sure how can ken and i
help
so dave i started your plan a little
while ago because my wife and i when we
got married she had some student debt
and to us the six thousand dollars was a
lot of money not knowing how to do it
but we paid it off and i'm so thankful
that she had it because that got us on a
budget that got us thinking financially
smart
and it put us
in contact with uh
your team and and we've followed your
principles along the way we have uh paid
off the debt and we have uh we actually
saved up a year emergency fund just
because of some you know things we've
seen in the world
uh going on but i'm actually to baby
step 3b
but
being so passionate like about not being
in debt and having this freedom
we truly
as a family we do not want to get a
mortgage we would like to
buy a house in cash and we're also very
patient people and we're willing to save
over the long run so my question to you
sir was how can we do that
and is it because we don't want because
we you know we know we shouldn't just
have our money sitting in the savings
account uh so where where do we park our
money during this time
how much are you trying to save
um our goal is to save up two hundred
thousand dollars okay and what's your
household income
uh fifty thousand dollars a year
and so when do you think you're going to
have two hundred thousand dollars
uh we would like to do it um with we're
about to have our first baby so we're
not we're not in a rush we would look to
do it in 10 years or possibly 20.
well a lot of difference in those two
so what you need to do is you need to
lay out a specific goal and then start
saving an amount that gets you there in
a very specific period of time any
amount of money you're going to leave
alone longer than five years you can
consider mutual funds for that
so what's your
career i work as a as a banquet server
but i work on palm beach island so it's
a pays really really well
i bet
and so this is the combined income is is
your wife gonna stay home when the baby
comes
yes my wife my wife will be staying home
when the baby comes so this is this is
my income
okay
do you have dreams do you have things
you at least wonder about as it relates
to your long-term professional purpose
uh yeah i really i really i work for
such a great company and i my dream is
to
to move up in the company and there
there has been hints um towards that i
only have been working there for not
even a year now but uh i'm very you know
i'm very diligent i'm very passionate
about customer service and and having
customers have just
like a top experience and it you know it
comes notice because customers will
comment on that so i do believe that
there's possibility that i can move up
and with moving up uh the pay does go up
as well there you go
i've heard
yeah well dave's right you guys have got
to decide what's the realistic goal here
to save up to 200 000 you've already got
a year's worth of expenses in the bank
for your emergency fund we teach three
to six months so you know if you get
serious about this and you go hey i want
to move up but i also want to make more
money so that i can get in that house
sooner i think that's the path man and i
think you're such a diligent sharp young
man
i'd get after it but i think dave 10
years versus 20 years that's that's a
long time to save for a house 20 years
yeah i think 10 years and i also think
you got a
you know you're not gonna extrapolate
fifty thousand we're not gonna just say
linear
no growth in in the right as a part of
our goal setting and our projections
we're gonna assume some kind of increase
in income as you go along yeah uh
sometimes it goes back a little and then
it comes up but overall people generally
earn more
throughout their careers because they
actually get better at it and do move up
jared is with us jared is in jefferson
city missouri hi jared how are you
i'm doing pretty good how are you guys
today better than we deserve what's up
well i'm trying to
i work a regular you know
i can't say nine to five because like i
work 3 a.m to 7 a.m sometimes but
i'm trying to find time to jump into
owning my own
automotive company and it just it really
scares me from going from a
strong steady thing to you know
something that
i have a lot of
passion for you know
what would be more specific what's this
automotive company is it mechanical what
are you doing
um it's going to be mechanical for like
engines transmissions
floyd lew tires you know just all-around
general maintenance are you doing any of
it on the side now
yeah um in fact we're i'm working with
my father-in-law and my brother-in-law
too and there while i'm working my
regular job there
we actually have a building right now
and
i got the name of the company
through the state all that stuff already
it's just
it's just
before i quit my job um
to go do this full time and it's just
it really terrifies me is this no i get
it well we're going to simplify this for
you because there's no jump involved
here so let's take this out of the
equation there's no jumping
uh are you but tell me about the
father-in-law or what's going on there
just say if partnership or is this your
business and they're gonna work for you
or they're just helping you get it going
what's that look like
um this is basically this is my business
but i just got started and they
came in and
they decided that
they'll do the
uh big work of it you know working on
the cars
while
i make the money
like with this job right now
to get things up and started great so
what do you make right now from your day
job what's your salary
uh
[Music]
really hard to tell because uh i work
agriculture so i drive trucks
so i bring in about what was your house
what was your income last year for the
whole year
um i actually jumped jobs since then
okay what do you think your income is
going to be in the coming year for a
year
um i'm hoping forty thousand
forty thousand dollars
okay
so if you were working this side job
with your brother-in-law and your
father-in-law working for you and your
company was making eighty thousand
dollars and you quit your day job that
really wouldn't be terrifying
i know it's just going from something
that's no no no no no stop
try it again
if you made 80 000 in the coming 12
months on your side hustle and you make
40 000 at your day job and you quit your
day job there's nothing terrifying about
that move
yeah nothing
i i agree with jumping okay so it has to
do with getting the income up so that
you don't jump
you take a step that's it you want to
step out of your old job into the new
one don't leap
there might not be any water in the pool
this
is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit chministries.org budget don't
worry
it's worth it
[Music]
well the last two years have been kind
of cray-cray haven't they
a lot to worry about out there
a lot of wondering what's going to
happen next
maybe that's how you feel about your
money maybe you're tired
maybe you're stuck maybe you're
stretched kind of thin
well it doesn't have to be that way
we can actually help you be the third
pig and get into the brick house and so
when the big bad wolf blows and huffs
and puffs and then you're okay right
you just need a plan
and a plan does give you confidence
the way we teach you that plan is a
class called financial peace university
almost 10 million people been through
this it'll teach you everything you need
to know
to save money
get out of debt become wealthy and
outrageously generous
you can stream the lessons on your own
or you can get support by going through
the class with other people or both
and you'll put that plan into practice
with a premium version of our every
dollar budgeting app
by syncing your bank to your budget you
can easily track your spending and see
where your money goes you get all of
this
with a ramsey plus membership
and you don't have to stay exhausted and
overwhelmed you can actually win with
money
to start your free trial of ramsey plus
text trial to 33 789
text trial two three three
seven
eight nine our question of the day comes
from blinds.com they're the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
always use the promo code ramsey today's
question comes from drew in indiana i
need advice regarding a potential new
job my current job pays an eighty five
thousand dollar base
over sixty five thousand in commission
plus i get a company car in full
benefits i have a new opportunity that
will pay a hundred and sixty two hundred
and seventy five thousand in base with
commissions the first year plus
insurance and stock options it does not
offer a company car which means i'll
need to purchase one i'm really happy my
current company but the new company is
an exciting startup with great potential
in a space i'm familiar with i keep
looking at that set monthly income from
this new opportunity and it's making me
think more emotionally than
strategically how do i weigh the
variables and look objectively at this
decision good question it's a great
question and drew's half answered it
for himself
the reality is is beyond the variables
let's start with the facts this is the
good old-fashioned grandma pros and cons
list for both opportunities the new one
the one where you are now then the
variables
and then you take out all the emotions
by just simply saying what on paper
positions me best for the desired future
i want that's where you're looking at
everything not just the bump in pay but
five years seven years 10 years 15 years
20 years down the line the last step
that i would add to this is go get some
advice from somebody you really respect
who doesn't have any emotion no dog in
this hunt show them all that information
and get some feedback and that's going
to help cement what i think he'll
already know by looking at it as a
future opportunity we're making this
decision not on the now
but the next yeah the way i
help that come home in my head is i
always say and i would say to myself as
well
okay
um let's say that uh
drew is
let's say he's 32 years old okay
and i say okay drew what would the 42
year old drew be glad you did
and that makes you think holistically
not just about the income or the
structure of the income
because here's the thing
there is no
security none
your only security you know it's a
secure job that's bull there's no
security in the job
you're only as secure as your ability
to go create the income in the
marketplace
and so straight commission is no scarier
than salary
because they'll fire you from a salary
job
and straight commission they just fire
you a little bit at a time that's right
and this is a startup so they hope to
pay you that but they're a startup yeah
and so i mean straight commission's not
scary if you make 300 grand a year no
straight commission's not scary if you
make 200 grand a year nothing scary
about it because you but you you really
have the true sense of the marketplace
that you are dependent upon
you getting up leaving the cave killing
something and dragging home you have to
produce
and you're dependent upon that when
you're in a commission situation
salary
moving to the salary is a
it's a false
positive
on the analysis
because it makes you feel like that's
more secure and it's no more secure than
fly the moon because let me just tell
you man if you don't go produce more
than you cost they're going to dump you
that's right all businesses have to have
team members that produce or cause to
put someone to produce more than they
cost yeah otherwise you don't you don't
have enough money to pay the payroll
they can't pay you
so you have to make them you have to add
more value than you take out of the
equation always
or you're in an insecure position yeah
so that that's the thing here and so
drew as you're doing what ken suggested
make sure that you don't
put too much weight on the supposed
security of the salary here yeah you
know there's another uh word that's
popping up and i've experienced this
with callers beyond the security this
also feels like the smart thing to do
think about it we as humans go i've been
offered more money that's the smart
thing to do so the converse is when your
heart and your strategy are both telling
you i shouldn't do this you're going but
everybody else is going to say i'm crazy
for not taking the guaranteed more money
so it's not just security it's also it
feels smart to take the bump in pay so
if that's the version of smart that's
going around out there let's try let's
say don't be smart that's right instead
be wise there it is that's exactly right
wisdom is the long play if smart as the
short play yeah you know it's strategy
play the long game yeah that's
absolutely right play the long game
mary is with us mary is in los angeles
hi mary welcome to the ramsey show
thank you for taking my call i
appreciate your time
we're a little um
concerned
about our situation my husband and i are
retired we're 65
we received pension and social security
uh we have a mortgage of uh probably
400 and maybe 50 60 000 on our own
we have an income after taxes of about
8
370 dollars per month
we do pay a lot out for
our bills
we have
um one
major bill that's 28 000.
we have a balance of about 10 000 on the
car
and
that's all our debt you don't have any
nest egg
we have fifty five thousand dollars in
the bank and about forty one thousand
and four fifty seven between the two of
us
okay
and write a check today and pay off your
car
okay but we don't wanna keep that car
then sell that car today
okay you need to get rid of the debt
okay okay that's first thing that's a
quick one easy one quick win
all right and so um
what's your house payment
2400.
okay with taxes and everything okay all
right
a little high but not a deal breaker
uh out of 8300 you can pay 2400 out of
83.70 and that leaves you 6 000 a month
to live on
you are in los angeles so you have a
high cost of living but you you know
once we wrote that check we've got
housing covered which is your big dog
if you've got no other debts because we
just started paying them off you have
six thousand dollars a month to live on
you can't live on that with a budget i
think you can even in l.a
but i have the 28 000 bill what's that
all right
we consolidated
a lot of bills and we did one it was
zero percent interest on a credit card
okay until next late next year okay so
you need to pay that off too
okay
so if you if you sell the truck the car
what are you going to be driving
we have one other vehicle okay
so if you sell the car and got rid of
that debt and you wrote a check and paid
that off it gets rid of a bunch of your
cash but you got all this stuff hanging
over your head i'm feeling the stress in
your voice from these debts
yeah and i want to set you free from
those debts and then you can start to
live on a budget and you can actually
save money in this situation of course
the other option is you could add income
to the equation
if you guys chose to have an encore
career you're just 65.
i'm 61 and i feel fine
you're gonna be all right
hold on i want to put you guys through
financial peace university it's time you
learned this stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at zip
recruiter have made the whole job search
way easier ziprecruiter is rated the
number one job site in the us by g2 and
it's free so how does it work
first go to ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
ziprecruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book the
proximity principle is my co-host today
his new book is from paycheck to purpose
the clear path to work you love it is on
sale now
it will actually be shipped and
delivered in the first week of november
so if you'd like to go ahead and reserve
your copy early uh you can do that for
20 and we'll throw in 100 worth of
extras
if you do that we'll bribe you to buy it
early pretty good return on your money i
mean it's only gonna be like two weeks
shut up so we'll get the book out to you
and you'll get the audio book the ebook
you'll get all kinds of other bundled
items in there check it all out at
ramseysolutions.com in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt free stage
with a question from san bernardino
california justin and sherry are with us
hey guys how are you good hi welcome
welcome how can ken and i help
so we're both teachers out in southern
california and uh cool what do you teach
i teach economics we actually use your
curriculum oh thank you changed the
lives of a lot of young people thank you
thank you
and uh i teach i teach robotics grades
seven through 12. wow nice
so i've been teaching for 19 years she's
been teaching for 22 years and um
for reasons i won't you already know
we love our lives in california our
family's there but we i don't think we
can stay in california anymore
so we came out here we have fall break
uh this week and we came out for just
originally when we booked you know the
airbnbs and and the airplane it was just
for vacation
um
we're going to the grand ole opry
tonight is why i'm wearing this silly
shirt but i love it she told me not to
wear it but anyways it's all good yeah
it looks fantastic hey man you're right
you're gonna fit right in yeah right
but anyways uh so we came out for
vacation and and a few things happened
right before our governor is crazy and
stuff and uh it
i think
it turned into more like a scouting trip
and so um
we're here in uh nashville area and then
we're going um tomorrow to chattanooga
and to check things out in tennessee
it's beautiful
the one hang up that we have is uh we
looked at the the salaries and we would
lose about a hundred thousand dollars if
if we came here per year per year
yeah they is all about seniority in
california not performance unfortunately
and so that's a hang up um
i'm 48 my wife is 46 and we'd be like
the new guy
at a job and that's we're having a
little trouble with that and then um we
do both of our folks are there they're
in their um early to mid 70s so
i guess i kind of know i think i know
what y'all would say but um what do you
think we would say well
i think you'd say go for it but i don't
know i
um
i guess i just wanted your advice and
clarity
we were thinking it's actually like a
million dollar we have 10 more years at
least to retire so it's like a million
dollar decision on income but happiness
might be more important than
well that's that's that's assuming you
would not get any raises during that ten
years that's right and let's also
assuming cost you didn't assume in the
uh cost of living adjustment plus we
don't have a state income tax here so i
think this is really you're you're
taking an emotional
decision and you're only applying the
mathematics you need to apply the
mathematics the financial but you also
have to look at the other side of this
and and that's and that's why you want
to leave in the life you want to live
and so i think you walk through the
numbers so okay let's talk about this so
do you have any debt where are you at
financially with your retirement what's
that going to look like
uh well we we followed your plan we've
taught the class uh four times i believe
um we've just paid off our house last
may we have no debt we haven't had debt
for 10 years we did the debt free of all
of our debt like maybe about 10 years
ago
and so we have no debt at all we just
how much is your house worth right now
house is worth about 450 000
okay all right
okay and then what do you think the
salary range is going to be based on
what little research you've been able to
do here in tennessee what's it going to
look like for both of you
about 65 000
each correct yeah okay okay that's
probably pretty close yeah yeah
so 130 and you're currently making 230
between the two correct perfect okay wow
wow
okay minus 15 percent
yeah income tax right state income tax
yeah right and we've noticed that things
are
yeah the food's cheaper and things are
cheaper we're finding yes
cost of living on non-housing items
would be different but it's not going to
be 25 different it's going to be 10 5
here there it's not i mean it's not like
a gallon of gas is different in
tennessee than it is in california not
much anyway
um the biggest issue would be the tax
savings
and housing differences are dramatic
obviously
um so
it's probably not a million dollar
decision it's probably a half a million
dollar decision
give or take maybe maybe cost of living
adjusted and tax adjusted
something like that uh over a 10-year
period of time um and
well well you would give you'd be
getting raises there you'd be getting
raises yeah so we would just call that
yeah that's fair
okay interesting that's a lot
that's a lot
and so um i i think you ask yourself um
you know a book i wrote the worst
selling book i ever did had a great
saying in it
[Laughter]
it's called more than enough it was a
total flop but uh i only sold like i
think i sold like 100 000 copies or
something compared to my other books it
was a flop yeah i'd like to point out a
public service announcement that's not a
flop but anyway it was it was a
follow-up to one that sold 2 million so
that's what you call a flop so but the
anyway in that book
this saying and it's a weird little
saying but it's true
only people only change when the pain of
same
where we are today
exceeds
the pain of change
and so the scale is
it's not a math scale it's how much pain
are you in
there
is it enough to say
i
this is scary and there's obviously a
down it's obviously a pay cut
we can call it whatever it's going to be
a pay cut 300 to 500 000 over 10 years
um are you in that much pain and you
don't have to answer that today on the
camera that's not fair to you but that's
the that's the heart question
the question your heart has to answer
um once you leave here and you go back
home
you go this is home
this is where my stuff is and it's a
beautiful state
i mean uh there's lots of crazy but it's
a beautiful state yes sir and a lot of
wonderful people there yes uh and so you
know and you've had great careers there
and you've got great memories there your
parents are there you can run back over
see the parents that's an airline ticket
that doesn't bother me okay we can get
back over there if they're if they're in
trouble they need some help you can get
over there that's not it's a three-hour
flight you can be there in no time lots
of six flights a day or whatever
non-stop to la it's not
uh not a problem but uh
i got a quick question a lot of roots
coming out of the ground here a lot of
roots i want to play into this math
thing a little bit i just want to wonder
together for a moment
what do you each love if you can give me
two or three words each what do you love
most about your profession
not don't give me environment or
anything i'm talking about the work
itself what do you love most about
teaching i love seeing the light bulb go
on in my students okay good good answer
um i i live i teach in a 100 percent
brain reduce lunch school
and so
uh
you can make a huge difference with kids
that have nothing like nothing going on
for them at all so
uh being able to see that you're moving
the needle yeah yeah i bet you are the
reason i asked that was twofold okay
number one i wanted you guys to hear
yourself say what really brings you joy
and meaning in your work and you can do
that in tennessee the second thing i was
just curious about is
you guys are young enough that you could
come to tennessee and take that same
type of work that you love and that
result that matters to you and
potentially transition into a completely
different than public education but a
career where you are training and
instructing because when i look at
teachers i look at a root word of what
they love the most and this the
functional thing that they love passion
what i call passion working love is
training or instruction would you agree
with that yes sir but the missional
result which is the results of the work
that that we all long for a mission that
drives us for you all it's influence
so where could you do that in tennessee
that's not in a traditional education
environment that wouldn't take you maybe
that long to get qualified for you don't
have to answer that i'm simply giving
you that as food for thought okay
do you start a a simple a primitive
version of that is do you start a
tutoring thing on the side
when you get to
tennessee texas or another state it's
not to be here i mean we love our state
but um
the whole point is the conversation is
not about tennessee versus california
the conversation's about what how to
make a move and how to
think through it critically and that's
what you're doing you're doing a great
job congratulations you guys proud of
you this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
brian is in spokane washington hi brian
welcome to the ramsay show
it's ryan but that's okay thanks for
taking my call sorry my bad i just read
brian on my screen because it was typed
there what's up that's right
um so my questions regarding uh
retirement um
i will have a pension when i retire it's
anywhere from 4 900 to 5500 depending on
what i choose for my
pension plan
i'm 50 years old i got 15 years left to
work is what i'm hoping
and you my company does a 401k match up
to seven percent great
at a half percent so it's three and a
half percent seven
um you always talk about the roth ira
and my company offers a
rocked 401k good
but i don't know if that's the same as
the it's not the same as the roth ira it
is but
okay it works exactly the same it's
after tax dollars
going into the account and it grows 100
tax free the difference is yours has a 7
match so you're doing this the match
portion is not roth the portion your
company puts in will be traditional
and you'll pay taxes on it and on the
growth of it when you get to retirement
so there'll be two segments to your 401k
the track taxable segment that was the
match and the tax-free segment that was
your roth and you definitely want to do
that at least to the tune of seven
percent of your income you may want to
do an individual otherwise if you don't
have good mutual funds in your 401k if
you've got good mutual funds to select
from in your 401k you can just do it all
there
okay yep and i think we do that and
i was thinking that obviously thinking
gets us in trouble but
i was thinking that if uh
i'm actually you making less money or
pulling less money out when i retire
that my taxes would be lower so
i'd be paying less on taxes than versus
now is that
not the case well the difference is this
the amount that you put in is not the
amount we worry about it's the growth
so let's say you save for 15 years and
there's a million dollars in that
account i'll just make up a number
because there would be probably okay
just for round numbers okay of that
million dollars 900 000 of it will be
growth
100 000 to be what you put in
you're either going to be taxed on that
900 000 or not
not is better than taxed
so i'd rather pay taxes now on the 100
000 and not pay taxes on the 900 000
later
okay it comes out way better so there's
uh yeah you're gonna come out
way way ahead and so uh yeah like light
years like 200 000 bucks per hundred
thousand or per million dollars ahead so
um yeah definitely do the roth and
definitely do we suggest four types of
mutual funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international
that's what i personally put my personal
roth 401k into at my company
and i obviously have those options
available for my team as well and they
do those that are in baby step four
uh do that as well i i assume everybody
that's doing this baby step four i don't
know i'm i don't check but
i think people pretty well follow our
stuff around here if they work here
don't you ken
yes the answer is absolutely yes all
right jerry's with us in saginaw
michigan hi jerry
hello how are you doing great what's up
quick question gloria so i've been
working for this rental car company for
the last 10 years
recently one of my stores closed as a
district manager
and now i have to drive two hours to
work each day leave around six in the
morning and get back at seven that sucks
um doesn't get
doesn't give me much time to look for a
job um where i'm located the reason i
have to stay two hours away is i have
seven kids two of my step kids and
they are with their dad at one week and
with us the next um we are on baby step
four or four five and six and we do have
emergency fund
should i leave my job and look for a new
job in the area
um
because it's kind of a struggle i've
been working the last couple months
what kind of store is this
again what's that what kind of store is
this again
it is uh the best rental car company
okay you guys have a studio with it okay
okay
so when you say you've been looking and
you can't find something or you said
well because of the time in the car i
don't have time to look
uh uh you're kind of discounting you
know at night and we got a job economy
right now where people are looking for
people with just a pulse
um what are you looking for because i'm
curious why you're not finding
opportunities to at least go for
so i'm putting resumes in um i'm doing
that
i make about 55 000 right now with a car
and gas
per year so i'm trying to find something
somewhat equal to take you know food for
my family and stuff so
trying to find something like that um
every couple days i'll be searching on
indeed and
and other stuff like that yeah all right
so so you are looking you are seeing
things are you getting interviews
i'm not getting any interviews okay so
there's a there's a i wrote an entire
book on a simple principle called the
proximity principle and it basically is
you've got to get around people that are
doing the kind of work you want to do so
if you want to stay in the rental car
game well you've got some relationships
you certainly had them before this
office was moved to another area but but
you just got to start working
relationships you know far more people
than you think you do and i can tell you
you know enough people and you've got to
say hey listen i got moved over here
it's too far of a commute because of the
family situation here's the type of
stuff i'm looking for i've got this
talent i love doing this kind of work
here's my experience and you have got to
connect connect connect connect connect
and then an opportunity for you to get
an interview is going to pop and then
they say oh by the way put your resume
in you're just kind of playing the job
lottery right now sending out resumes
right now uh is not an effective way to
do this it never is an effect ever uh we
read an article i shared an article last
week on the ken coleman show where they
are saying now that 10 million qualified
candidates resumes weren't even seen in
the last 12 months 10 million 10 million
so you jerry i'm not getting on you i'm
actually encouraging you because if you
start doing good old-fashioned
uh shoe leather out there talking to
people and i know you're driving a lot
but that's two hours in the car where
we're calling people phones all the way
over and all the way up absolutely your
opportunity is just waiting for you but
it's gonna come through a relationship
yeah you're gonna have to have some kind
of a connection yeah and you filling out
applications is a complete waste of time
if you're just doing it blindly and
you're just you know i'll give you an
example okay we've got 300 jobs on the
board we're trying to hire this year
we will get 23 000 applications for
those 300 jobs
you know what the chances are one of
those applications turning into one of
those jobs
almost zero
unless someone does something to get
themselves out of that pile the primary
way to get out of the pile is to know
somebody inside the building or know
somebody that knows somebody inside the
building and say hey would you ask them
to pull mine out of the pile and at
least give me a look
and uh i've even got friends i own the
company and i've even got friends that
call me hey someone says daughter is put
in an application over here and i'm like
well that's great and i i will ping hr
and say so-and-so's daughter's apps in
the file would you pull it out i don't
tell him to hire her i never do that but
i say you know would y'all at least give
her a look give her an interview and um
you know the guy that owns the company
said to do it then they'll do it or if
you know sharon calls it's even more
powerful than that
but yeah you need you need to have a
connection and listen go to
kencoleman.com download everything he's
got over there on resume templates on uh
letters to write to get in the door to
try to figure out your connectivity and
i will give you a copy of ken's first
book the proximity principle which will
get you going because that's exactly
what you need here um but you can't use
the excuse of i don't have time to
interview you have two hours a day yeah
yeah
or no four hours a day yeah and that's
not to mention after the kids are in bed
too you're emailing everybody you know
you're testing take some vacation time
yes if you've got some interviews that
have to be done during work hours yeah
and go go sit down with somebody because
this is a time i mean you're in a
buyer's market dude yep this is uh you
you are in the driver's seat more than
ever before on getting a new job yeah
everyone is and the answer to your
initial question should you yes yes
you should this is going to suck the
soul out of your
body is it sounds like it's all out of
my body and i'm not even doing it yeah
dad gum two hours a day each direction
commuting yeah that's like driving the
knoxville and back yeah
just shoot me
oh man i drive 14 minutes and i'm crying
about that like oh man
unbelievable
there you go
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage is actually an
indication that you're probably an
everyday millionaire
this is the ramsay show it's an everyday
millionaire theme hour here on the
ramsey show we're going to talk about
everyday millionaires baby step
millionaires and millionaires in general
where they really come from
a thousand years ago when i was in
college
computers were just
starting to be a thing
this is the early 1980s
and i distinctly remember one of our
computer professors and one of our
marketing professors
saying
that it is not too far in the future
that our problem will not be
a lack of information our problem will
be too much information
that we will have so much data
so many data points so much information
that we will be unable
to wade through it all and make sense of
it all
well that was very prophetic
they had no idea that facebook was
coming on the scene no idea that twitter
was coming on the scene
no idea that instagram and etc etc tick
tock etc was coming on the scene
and so now we have not only
too much information
we have way too many people that
have
the ability to give us information who
don't know what they're talking about
mainly social media but even the media
because you can just stand up a blog and
say i'm an expert
i'm an expert on finance i live in my
mother's basement but i'm an expert on
finance
uh and so everybody seems to have an
opinion and then the thing that went
with that was this idea that your
opinion actually matters
that's an entitlement thing it's a
participation trophy thing
it's a
you know so let me help you with this
uh
my opinion
about something
that i know nothing about
doesn't matter
i'm a smart guy
i built a large business i'm
work really hard
but
my opinion about hair care products
does not matter i have no knowledge of
them and so for me to express my opinion
ferociously about hair care products
just shows that i'm an idiot
that's all it would show
it doesn't mean i'm not intelligent it
doesn't mean i don't have value as a
human being it means i have no knowledge
of that so i should keep my freaking
trap shut
but in our world today
no one does that because everyone thinks
that their opinion matters even though
they have nothing to say about it and
have no expertise on it and so they run
around mouthing off all over the
internet and you know if it says it on
the internet it must be true abraham
lincoln quoted that
so i mean this is the kind of stupidity
that's out there and so
this this leads into this whole idea
about money and wealth
so have you heard
that wealth inequality is a problem in
america
have you heard that the only way to get
rich in america is to
inherit your money
to be
a professional
sports star
or a music act or an actor in hollywood
have you heard that you know the only
way to build wealth is to hit the lotto
because
and they always say it with a wine
the little man
can't get ahead
well i've watched the little man become
wealthy for 30 years teaching what i
teach doing what i do
and observing people with common sense
and dignity going about their business
and doing what they're supposed to
getting out of debt living unless they
make being on a plan investing in their
401k getting their house paid off and
voila they become a millionaire we
started calling them everyday
millionaires we were seeing them
everywhere around us and none of these
people inherited their money and none of
them were
famous and they were
devastatingly regular people
singularly unimpressive
except for the fact that they did what
very few people in this whiny but
opinionated culture will actually go do
they got up off their butt left the cave
killed something drug at home and took
responsibility for their own lives
touchdown
score
and became millionaires and they do it
really quietly and you run into them you
never know
they don't really they're not like fancy
dressers they don't drive lamborghinis
they're not billionaires they're
millionaires a millionaire is someone
who has a million dollar net worth your
net worth is what you own minus what you
owe your assets minus your liabilities
equals one million dollars you're a
millionaire well it doesn't sound like a
lot of money well it isn't a lot of
money but it's more money than most
people got
and it's not lamborghini money it's not
private jet money
but it is i'm going to live a good life
and i'm not dependent on social
insecurity
to feed me
money
because if you invested you could have
an income around 100 000 a year while
you sit on your butt
okay so that's that's what a million
dollars will do for you so it's worth it
so we started studying millionaires and
then we got everybody started saying
ramsay you don't know what you're
talking about you just don't understand
the little man can't get ahead socialism
is the way
you capitalist pigs you you people have
lost your minds and you just can't do
this and you don't you're just you're
ignorant and and i kept going yeah but i
keep meeting them everywhere so we
actually
commissioned a study the largest study
of millionaires ever done and our
research team combined with some outside
research resources and did an airtight
statistical analysis of the largest
study of millionaires ever done in north
america over 10 000 millionaires studied
and we're going to talk to real
millionaires this hour
to show you what we found we didn't set
these calls up we didn't tell anybody
what to say we asked them to call at a
certain time or allowed us to call a
certain time but they're not scripted
we just said if you have a million
dollar net worth we want to talk to you
because we want to learn what real
millionaires do not what some broke
[ __ ] in his mother's basement who has
an opinion about socialism thinks
you're just a little broken [ __ ] honey
i hope you grow up and get better
but right now you're too stupid and you
should keep your opinions to yourself
because you're misleading people when
you say the little man can't get ahead
because he does every day
and it makes me angry when you convince
some little man that he can't get ahead
because you can get ahead
you can beat all the isms
and there's lots of isms out there
and they're very real
there's some ignorant people that will
discriminate against you based on
the most ridiculous of things
and you have to be you have to beat them
too
and you have to go around the morons
that do that kind of stuff but it can be
done folks i meet people of every race
creed color national origin immigrant
born north south fat skinny bald or a
beautiful head of hair who have become
everyday millionaires starting from
nothing
i meet them everywhere we're going to
talk to millionaires this hour
only
not your broke brother-in-law with an
opinion
we're going to talk to real ones and see
what they say
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over seventy dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire theme hour
here on the ramsey show we're talking to
real millionaires matt is in milwaukee
wisconsin matt what is your net worth
hey dave about four mil cool give me a
little breakdown on that how's it mixed
up between your retirement and real
estate and so forth
sure
yeah we have about 1.5 in mutual funds
maybe 900 in real estate that's a paid
for house and a piece of recreational
property that we paid cash for
and the rest 1.6 and change is in
retirement accounts mostly ross and
things like that cool how old are you
i'm 37. good well done
and how much of this did you inherit
i didn't inherit any of it dave okay
and what is the range of your income
household income from uh worst income
year to best income year
well the day that i listened to you for
the first time my wife and i made
about 50 000 combined
and in that time that was in 2007
our highest income year now was just
over 500. whoa
good for you what do you do for a living
she's a
sort of a corporate exec in hr and i'm a
consultant and that came because of one
of the lessons that i got in financial
peace university the first one talked
about
money being amoral
and how it's okay to go out and live a
meaningful life through a meaningful job
but it's also okay
to make money doing it and for some
reason that lesson was just never
never bestowed upon me i was always
willing to work hard uh what do you say
leave the cave kill and drag at home but
some work pays more than others but
there was there was shame associated
with making money before and that took
it away
for some reason yeah it was embedded in
there somewhere what's your degree in
my degrees in political science and
finance okay and what was your gpa
it was in the high threes three six
three seven got it okay cool and how
much of this debt i mean how much of
this net worth is there because you
borrowed money to make money well in
2008 we called into your show my wife
and i and did our debt free screen
together with you and that was the last
time we borrowed money we had credit
card debt and student loans and for the
year from when i first started listening
to you to when we
um
had our debt free stream i actually get
emotional thinking about this um we
never borrowed again
except for the house and we paid it off
in four years yeah so you didn't become
wealthy because of borrowed money
no sir quite the opposite okay cool
well you did this really quick at 37 and
just 13 years that's pretty incredible
very very well done uh from this from
the point you said ready set go so what
advice do you give to that uh 22 year
old out there listening that 28 year old
out there listening
yeah i was 24 when i heard your radio
program the first time
and the first is one you've talked about
a lot you just cannot take financial
advice from both people
or for most people because most people
are broke you have to go out and seek
out and emulate people who really do it
the right way and they're actually kind
of hard to find as you said in the
opening of your show today it's sort of
an unassuming group of people i would
consider us inside that category
and then the second is if you're
fortunate enough to be able to get a
high income and have excess money
act for a little while like you don't
and just give yourself permission to
save a bunch and give a bunch for a
while
and you just don't quite know what could
happen from 22 to 28 and it won't happen
for everybody but where it does
it's okay what'd you pay for your last
pair of jeans
ooh not very much 25
although i have to admit that is my sort
of a weak spot for me i do buy um sort
of like expensive hunting clothes now so
that's my that's my advice you got four
million dollars dude
it's okay
i know right it's hard to wear off
though you know like you do it for a
while it's hard no you said you said
unassuming and that's that's exactly
right yeah i'll definitely spend more on
a gun than a willow shirt
hey man congratulations i'm very proud
of you well done an everyday millionaire
hey real millionaires are who we're
talking to kim is one she's in atlanta
kim what's your net
worth hey dave uh we got a net worth
right now at about 2.4 million cool give
me a little breakdown on that by
category
so we're a little different than a lot
of folks most of ours is actually in our
retirement savings we've got about 1.8
sitting there
and then we have a house that's about
450 000 and then the rest of it is just
in miscellaneous
mutual funds and that kind of thing so
you just loaded up the old 401k
i did i really did um
my husband
so i'm 53 my husband's 52. so how much
of this 2.4 did you inherit
not one time zero
and your income worst year
event household income to best year of
household income
probably our worst year was around
eighty thousand and now we're at about 2
20 to 2 30. cool what do y'all do for a
living
my husband is an aircraft mechanic for a
commercial airline and i am a
i work with a pharmaceutical company and
sales ah good both good jobs good so
what's your degree in
i have a microbiology degree okay and
what was your um yeah a good use of that
um yes
it really was i mean you actually know
the science yeah so the um yeah your gpa
was what
um i think i was around 3.6 when i
graduated cool all right
so uh you're 53 years old you got 2.4
million dollars you inherited none of it
you mainly due to your 401k
um someone's listening out there this is
the first time they've ever turned on
the ramsey show they're riding along in
their car and they're going what have i
found here and the 53 year old genius
who's got 2.4 million dollars tells them
they're 25 years old a can they do this
and b if they can what what should they
do
well so i have a 22 year old son so this
is the advice we've given to him is that
while we have a wonderful you know nest
egg of 2.4 it could easily have been
triple that if we had been a lot more
careful with our money when we were
younger
and just staying out of debt
would have made such a difference for us
if we had not gotten specifically more
me than my husband i'm the spender he's
the nerd um if i had not been so
careless with you know i got a good job
and i thought i could just out earn my
stupidity so to speak and that just
didn't really work in the beginning so i
had some pretty poor money habits that
thankfully we were over to overcome
after a while but at least the one
saving grace that i had was my husband's
voice of reason saying well if you're
not going to save it in a savings
account where you're afraid you're going
to spend it at least put it in your 401k
and so we did we always maxed those out
but
really you know it's not complicated
it's just simple just to try to avoid
debt and don't
spend more than you earn you know live
below your means and when we bought our
first house we bought it based on one of
our incomes so that either of us ever
lost the job we wouldn't lose our home
and i think that was a really smart
thing that we did too
yeah
did during this time that you were doing
all this did you guys
enjoy vacations did you have a life or
did you just live in a cave and collect
lent
so
i like i said i'm the spender i actually
have a very expensive hobby that i was
never willing to give up or sacrifice
and that was where a lot of my money
went i'm an equestrian so i compete and
ride horses yeah that's
nothing cheap about that
yeah exactly and then our daughter does
it as well so there were two of us doing
it
um so we did do that and and we always
tried to plan at least one vacation a
year um and we would save up for that
and we you know we tried to not use debt
to
do vacations so let's let's let's lay up
let's say a fact out there because
you're fairly common fairly typical
among millionaires
fact
when someone says
i need to yolo
because you never know
right i need to i need to i need to live
now i wouldn't want to live like that i
might die later the fact is
you have had a good life
you've not lived in a cave collect lent
no never seen the sun shine and just so
you could be a millionaire you didn't
trade your entire existence a quality
existence on the planet
for this money you went and had a good
life and save some money because you're
intentional that's a fact
so hey yolo
stop your freaking childish whining
[Music]
be an adult
was i unclear
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
it's an everyday millionaire female
we're talking to real millionaires
people have a million dollar net worth
or greater asking them
what they did how they did it
[Music]
don't follow the financial advisor from
broke people talk to people that have
money if you want to follow a money
plan kind of a cool idea best practices
kevin is in orlando florida hi kevin
what's your net worth
hey dave uh we're just over a million
about a million fifty thousand good for
you
all right and break that down for me a
little bit how much what categories
yeah 650 000 is in 401k ira and the kids
college funds
we've got about 120 000 between our cars
and cash and then our house is 450 000
but we still have 140 000 dollar
mortgage on it
got it okay cool how old are you
41. and your price is 40. yeah cool how
much of the million dollars did you
inherit
about five thousand dollars a few years
ago when my grandfather passed away so
you're not a millionaire because of
inheritance all right and your
range of income your best working your
household income and your worst working
your household income
uh the range was anywhere from about
forty thousand uh now up that are about
two hundred thousand cool what do you do
for a living what do you all do
uh i'm an airline pilot my wife is a
stay-at-home mother
cool and what's your degree in
uh business
cool
and uh what was your gpa
mine wasn't great it was about 3.0 in
college my wife is the brains in the
family she was close to 4.0 okay all
right good
very good cool all right you're 41 years
old you did it congratulations you're
not done yet you got plenty of time to
make this 1 million into 10 million
pretty easily as a matter of fact um
what do you tell people that are
25 years old can they still do this in
today's america and if so what should
they do to do it
they can absolutely do it and uh the
first thing is
um i'm sorry about that you cut out the
first thing is what is you need to work
hard oh there's that yeah
work hard but enjoy life but uh the big
thing is stay out of debt i wish we had
done that sooner we only got out of debt
aside from the house about four years
ago
once we got serious about following your
plan
um but the last thing i think that's
most important is uh
we grew up catholic christian
and uh it's important to tithe um i was
taught from a young age and we carry
through today that
god will always take care of you i think
that tithing is important give ten
percent of your income back to him
and uh your needs will be met and i
think that goes a long way into helping
you achieve financial freedom yeah
that's pretty cool yeah you can't really
mess up being generous
it's a basic principle because it
changes you
it makes you into a better more
attractive person
and uh i mean generous people are just
more attractive than selfish people i'm
just saying
yep i i agree
and uh yeah i just it just and it causes
life to be better so well done
very very very well done so uh are you
are you a tv family or a book reading
family
um we watch a little bit of tv uh i'm
not a huge book reader i tend to read a
lot of technical publications associated
with my job in aviation but
my wife is a big reader she probably
reads i don't know at least two maybe
three books a month fashion and
non-fiction wow okay good very cool
very cool hey kevin thanks for your time
and thanks for sharing your story
congratulations you're doing it man
you're a hero you took control of your
life you took control of your destiny
that's how life works if you want to do
it well charlotte's in cincinnati hey
charlotte what's your net worth
oh dave it's right around 1 million good
for you give me a little breakdown on
that
well i'll tell you we owe it all to you
dave for getting it for helping us get
out of debt we have 450 000 in various
retirement accounts
we have about 150 000 in a taxable
brokerage account
we have 300k in our house and we have
about 100k in cash good for you good for
you very good how old are you
i'm 50 and my husband is 52. okay
excellent how much of this one million
dollars did you inherit
we inherited zero okay
and what is the best year of your
work household income working income
best year and worst year range
uh when we first got married we made
about twenty five thousand dollars and
um recently it's been around two hundred
thousand
but um this last year and a half we've
been living off of one salary because of
covid and some medical things and that
was easy to do because we were out of
debt so
um
and it's going back up as of tomorrow
the job the new job starts oh good
excellent very good okay what do you
guys do for a living
my husband is a director of technology
and i am a teacher
excellent okay
and um so you have a degree in what
i have a master's degree in education
and my husband has a bachelor's degree
in communication okay and what was your
gpa
mine was 3.9
and my my husband likes to tell the kids
that they didn't have gpas back when he
went to school
i like that
i like that and there were no pretty
girls on campus but your mother yeah
i like this guy oh that's fun
so how much of this one million dollars
is there because you borrowed money to
create wealth with borrowed money
i i would say very little um we really
kind of screwed up a long time before we
started your plan 10 years ago and
really everything we borrowed just got
us into trouble so
yeah so you're basically the debt was a
something holding you back not
propelling you forward
absolutely absolutely as soon as we
started your program things turned
around so it's all from just hard work
and saving
what advice do you have to the
25 year old version of you out there
well we are blessed with two kids in
that age range right now and we talk a
lot about this with them i'll tell you
the advice we gave them
so live below your means
take debt off the table as an option
don't even consider it
don't listen to broke people and invest
as early as you can
and be content with what you have
yeah that's powerful that's really good
you can fill in for me when i'm off the
air one day
great job hey charlotte i'm so proud of
you guys very very very well done
bob is in indianapolis bob what's your
net worth
uh 1.1 million sir good for you and give
me a little breakdown on that
a house uh roughly
a quarter million uh 401k slash
you know savings cash about 450 000 and
then our business worth is at least 400
000 being a little conservative there
yeah okay cool how old are you
34 and my wife is 32. wow good for you
sir how much of this 1.1 million did you
inherit
uh zero we inherited a work ethic from
our payment
inherited hard freaking work i like it
so household income the best year and
the worst year since you guys have been
working
you know the crazy thing we've been
married 10 years and we've never made
like crazy money like you know maybe at
the beginning like 50 now
maybe close to 75
my wife is kind of a stay-at-home mom
slash that helps with the business
and so what kind of business have you
got a roofing business
ah that's hard work but also very
profitable good for you you got a
four-year degree
uh no sir we both actually have
associate's degrees okay and so what was
your associate's degree in
uh environmental engineering okay and
what was your gpa
uh
i may have got a 3.0 it may have been
just a hair below that so
that works i graduated thank you lottie
so there you go yeah yeah good for you
man congratulations
okay in just a second you're 34 years
old you're a millionaire did you ever
think in america today you were going to
do that
you know no but we've been i've been
following you probably for 11 12 years
so just following your advice on money
but
everything you know
family wife kids all that kind of just
adds up i am so proud of you brother
very very well done congratulations
it's an everyday
millionaire
theme hour if you want to read about
these folks you can read about them in
the book we have for sale called
everyday millionaires oh there you go
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today deuteronomy 8 18
remember the lord your god for it is he
who gives you
the ability to produce wealth
and so confirms his covenant which he
swore to your ancestors
as it is today
i never dreamed about success i worked
for it estee lauder said
who by the way started from nothing
so we're talking to real millionaires
this hour
people have a one million dollar net
worth or greater it's an everyday
millionaire theme hour a lot of these
are baby steps millionaires meaning they
follow the baby steps that we teach in
financial peace university and became
millionaires doing that
not everybody did that but we'll talk to
you i don't care if you if you won the
lottery i'll talk to you
if your grandpa died and left you 10
million dollars i'll talk to you i want
to find out where wealth comes from
and i've been studying this anecdotally
here on the air with people for years
now doing this theme hour
and of course we did
commission and conduct
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america
and for those of you who question that
the research is airtight i
dare you to do a statistical analysis
and find anything wrong with our
surveying process or what we did
by the way we randomly asked people to
call in that are millionaires here and
this is what we get
uh we didn't
hand select or rule out anyone to be on
the air as long as they have a million
dollar net worth
alan is with us alan's in denver
colorado alan what's your net worth
2.3 million good for you give me a
little breakdown on that by category
okay about 40 of it's in
our house and then in a vacant lot we
got a
good buy on about 40 of us in retirement
accounts
and the balance of 20 is in
some non-qualified mutual funds and in
cash
cool
good for you well done how old are you
59. 59 years old i've met you several
times in various events well i'm honored
thank you good for you thank you how
much of this 2.3 did you inherit
uh my parents passed away earlier this
year so i got about 250 000 from them
that was enough to push it from about
two to 2.3 million okay so you were
already a millionaire so you did not
become a millionaire because of an
inheritance but you added to it with
that
correct that allowed me to pay my house
off oh very nice good good okay
and your best year household income and
worst year household income since you
guys have been working
since i started working i was probably
about 60 000 during my
single working years and after getting
married 100 000 for the first half of it
and about 150 000
combined the last 10 years gotcha what
do you do for a living
well now i'm early retired i had worked
at the telephone company in california
for several years what'd you do there
i was various middle management jobs of
sales and marketing okay all right cool
what's your degree in marketing
uh i have an mba and then a bachelor's
in chemistry okay cool what was your gpa
for the mba
3.4 good for you very cool
all right so you're 59 years old there's
a 29 year old listening that has 30
years to get where you are
uh can they do it
absolutely they can do it i would have
done it much sooner had i not made a
whole bunch of errors
me too
i think we had a lot of carbon copies
yeah he made it quicker than i did yeah
i lost it quicker yeah so uh what would
you tell people then the secret to
getting to a 2.3 million dollar net
worth
working for the telephone company with
an mba at 59 years old is
keep putting money in the 401k even when
you're making mistakes outside of your
work in a basically losing everything
you have so at least you have a seed
base there
and if something doesn't seem right go
and ask a second opinion like your
parents
you probably would have
probably would have uh
saved you 10 years of your life
yeah and not not made friends with wrong
people
yep that'll do it
that'll do it that'll bite you big time
hey man thank you for the call and
congratulations your hero you did it i
am so
very proud of you i'm so proud of you
well done
okay
so today
4 million 2.4 million 1 million 1
million 1.1 and 2.3 is who we
interviewed 37 years old 53 41 50 years
old 34 years old 59 years old
none of them were 87.
as a matter of fact
none of them were even over 60.
that's fairly interesting
a consultant pharmaceutical sales
airline pilot a teacher a technology guy
a roofing company
and a telephone marketing executive
i didn't hear any nba players
nfl players
no famous actors
no recognizable household names
uh oh you have to be a genius to be well
be wealthy in america today nope no 4.0s
one guy married a 4.0 everybody else was
in the threes
3.4 3.0 3.9 3.0 3.6 3.6 gpas
by the way that's the average is 3.6 of
all the millionaires we studied
no it's not 2.6 you have to have a level
of intelligence an ability to apply
yourself
i got a um
i'm still mad about it
i agree i worked 40 to 60 hours a week
when i was in college and i graduated
with a 2.97
three one hundredths of a point i'm
still bitter after all these years but
there you go is that close
too much beer too much work not enough
study
and i still made it out okay
there's no crooks now these people were
stealing for people all the rich people
they just steal from people they just
beat up the little man you are such a
bunch of whiners out there the
wussification of america
it's unbelievable
it's just not true is the problem
if it was true
all your whining might be better off
but what you're whining is telling
people that they can't do something that
they can do and you're stealing hope
from your own children
and from people you have influence over
and you ought to be ashamed of yourself
because you should be full of hope in
america today i know it's cray-cray out
there i know there's a bunch of nut
burgers running around the streets i
understand i see the stuff too i know
what's going on but you know what in
spite of all of that there's more
regular good people than nut burgers the
ratio of nut burgers is just about as
low as it's always been in civilization
there's always a percentage of cray-cray
out there it's just part of the deal
two percent of the public should be
institutionalized
they should be in a rubber room
somewhere but the rest of us are just
regular folk we love our kids we pet our
dogs
we like our spouse
yes we actually like our spouse we love
them but we also like them
isn't that weird but i mean nothing
there's nothing on television that
indicates that that's a normal thing but
it's typical
these people get up they go to work they
live on less than they make they put
money in their 401k
and they get their house paid off really
sexy
really mysterious
it's not mysterious at all it's just
common sense but common sense is so rare
that when you have it today it's like
having a superpower
it puts you in a completely different
stratosphere from
the characters that are just living for
the weekend
thank god it's friday
oh god it's monday
yolo you only live once so be sure you
spend it all by saturday night
you little freaking four-year-old
you're four years old emotionally
you cannot get through uh you cannot
open a bag of candy without eating the
whole bag
unbelievable
zero adult discipline one definition of
maturity
is the ability to delay pleasure
and we live in a very immature culture
so just being a grown-up puts you way
ahead of other people we live in a
culture where adulting is now a verb
this is how rare it is
acting like an adult is now a verb
it's not a state of being anymore
this is where we live so can you become
a millionaire oh definitely
the bar is fairly low actually
can you be successful in this crazy
world you bet
show up smile work hard be kind work
hard work while you're at work get off
your social media account somebody's
paying you you little thief
work
this is how it works guys it's not hard
you can do this
that puts us hour of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you